if it's the snow-white tail you're
looking for discover the story that came
before mirror mirror on the wall who is
the fairest of you are my queen but not
for long
your sister is a baby who will grow to
be more beautiful than you but beware
should any harm come to the child
your sister will unleash a power unlike
anything the world
to escape the pain of her loss good
Queen built a fortress of ice around her
heart if she could not raise a child she
would raise an army
you will train he was become
my Huntsman
nice sure
I stopped I made you strong but you're
as pathetic as you ever were this is my
kingdom
did you say something with the Mary's
magic I'll fool
that matters an even dangerous thing we
have to destroy
what are you gonna do be the hero who
defeats America and saves the entire
kingdom I pretty much
are you ready hon Smith
I'm stronger than all of you shall we
find out the story before snow white
either the Tunisian Yvetta toys extend
your various minor Huntsman